au sommaire le rempart de la rivière de
l'est l'une des portions les plus
spectaculaires du caldera trail la
curiosité de la semaine gourmandise à la
plaine des quatre
rendez vous sur la route forestière du
volcan après avoir dépassé le bois ouzou
et avant d'atteindre le cratère
commerson vous pourrez vous garer sur ce
petit parking au dessus de la rabine de
la rivière des remparts
pour cette randonnée facile de 6 km
prévoir de quoi vous protéger du soleil
et du froid des vivres et une réserve
d'eau
pour votre santé
parcourez nos sentiers
la deuxième édition du cadet ratera il
aura lieu le samedi 13 avril intégré
cette année au challenge saint rolan
elle devient la course la plus longue
après le grand raid 80 km entre piton
sainte-rose et la plaine des palmistes
qui permettent de faire le tour quasi
complet du volcan le rempart de la
rivière de l'est est l'une des portions
les plus spectaculaires de la course un
itinéraire parfait pour une randonnée
que nous allons découvrir en compagnie
de patrick l'organisateur du caldera
trail une fois rejoint l'oratoire sainte
thérèse
ici les coureurs donc arrive depuis là
depuis la plaine des sables l'oratoire
sainte thérèse et ils ont dans les
jambes donc environ 65 66 km les
coureurs donc on va faire 15 km pour
arriver au textor piton textor qui sera
le dernier ravitaillement et pour se
rendre à textor l'organisateur avait le
choix entre plusieurs possibilités la
plus rapide étant celle du gr 2 mais le
caldera trail c'est avant tout un
concept qu'on va te passe par ici donc
là on descend vers la plaine des cafres
et on coupe la route plusieurs fois et
c'est du sentier connu le principe de la
caldeira c'est de suivre quand même fait
fameuse caldera donc cet effondrement
est de prendre le plus possible cette
crête en s'engageant sur le sentier du
rempart de la rivière de l'est on
comprend l'intérêt d'une telle option en
surplombant de 400 mètres le fond de la
rivière de l'est la vue est saisissante
à la fois sur le volcan la plaine des
sables ou le plateau des basaltes mais
aussi de l'autre côté sur le piton des
neiges
sans un nuage ce jour là les conditions
sont idéales certains coureurs ont
d'ailleurs fait le choix d'y venir
s'entraîner comme freddy thévenin le
vainqueur en titre du caldera toi qui
connais bien tous les itinéraires qu'est
ce qui te plaît sur cette partie en
particulier
le petit nicolas est descendu seulement
avoir déroulant jusqu'à la plaine du
rhône une belle descente après testo a
terminé loin des palmistes
courir sur les remparts permet une vue
vertigineuse mais pas seulement le
concept de la course est aussi de
découvrir ce qui fait la particularité
de ces paysages de comprendre ce qu'est
une caldeira
les caldera ou cratères sont des
structures géologiques caractéristiques
des volcans de type hawaïen comme la
fournaise elles sont apparues suite à
des affaissements du cône volcanique les
caldera sont la base de ces paysages si
typique et qui ont valu à la réunion
d'être inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
après avoir dépassé le piton de la
rivière de l'est le sentier qui clôt
remparts en direction du piton de l'eau
la descente permet d'observer une grande
partie de cette zone de pâturage encore
bien active
après quelques centaines de mètres à
l'ombre des tamarins le sentier abouti
sur la route forestière du piton de
l'eau d'ici deux choix sont possibles
revenir par le même chemin ou comme les
coureurs continuer jusqu'à textor pour
faire une boucle
cette portion c'est ma préférée parce
qu'elle est elle est facile à faire
depuis la route et si ça peut être une
promenade très sympathique familiale et
en même temps on a le point de vue à
partir de 2003 s'en mêle c'est vrai que
le paysage est peut-être le plus joli en
effet puisqu'il ya d'autre qu'une ligne
de crête mais où le paysage est plus
monotone on ne voit que le volcan on ne
voit que la mer là on est vraiment
presque entre donc le piton des neiges
et puis le piton de la fournaise on voit
les deux pitons les deux montagnes de la
règion en fait les deux massifs le but
moi c'est j'ai rêvé et donc j'aimerais
que balayé le court en rêve et se
fassent plaisir c'est ça le but de ses
soeurs plusieurs ce que j'aime moi c'est
le fait qu'ils aient mauvais temps que
tous soient couverts et que finalement
il n'y a aucun paysage visible sur
l'ensemble du parcours et souvent on a
donc c'est cette température et puis
surtout cette couverture nuageuse qui
empêcherait les coureurs de voir le beau
paysage donc ce sera un peu dommage de
rater de rater ça
chocolats macarons et autres friandises
depuis sept ans un véritable laboratoire
à gourmandise ces niches est la plaine
des cafres et rayonne dans toute l'île
la chocolaterie pâtisserie coco cannelle
et notre curiosité de la semaine
vous êtes actuellement dans le
laboratoire de coco cannelle de
laboratoires de fabrication donc situé à
bourg murat au 27e kilomètre coco km
c'est une pâtisserie sur commande on
travaille essentiellement sur des
wedding cake des macarons et des
chocolats dans le laboratoire on a une
pièce centrale pour tout ce qui est
macarons et wedding cakes et après des
pièces climatisées pour tout ce qui va
être chocolat chacun a plus ou moins son
poste donc on va voir des personnes qui
sont qui sont plus calés en décoration
après on a les personnes qui sont
opérationnelles sur les macarons donc
tout ce qui va être les garnitures à la
fabrication des coques et tout ce qui
est chocolat donc partie bonbons
chocolats donc tout ce qui est en rodage
et partie moulage
on a tout à fait adapté les parfums de
macarons aux saveurs locales on a de la
mangue on a de la goyave y est on a dû
crème de cannes dont crème de cannes on
a un mélange de sirop l'acuité de sucre
vergeoise en chocolat on allait les
scories qui sont fabriqués à base de led
de la plaine et enrobés dans des
les amandes caramélisées du groupe wikio
ça fait maintenant 15 ans que je
travaille et c'est toujours le même
esprit qui m'anime c'est à dire essayer
de proposer les meilleurs produits
d'apporter du bonheur aux gens c'est
tellement énorme de proposer du bonheur
et que les gens nous rend tellement que
voilà c'est ça qu'il y avait de
l'essence dans la machine